hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to be
doing an nclex practice question
specifically over
calcitonin which is used to treat
osteoporosis
so let's take a look at our nclex
practice question your patient who has
osteoporosis is prescribed to take
calcitonin
which assessment finding below is a
possible adverse reaction of this
medication and requires you to notify
the physician immediately
a constipation
b abdominal pain that is found at one
third distance between the belly button
and anterior superior iliac spine
c
carpopetal spasm while assessing the
patient's blood pressure or d absent
reflexes okay so we learned from our
scenario that this patient has
osteoporosis and that they're prescribed
calcitonin so we really need to know
what osteoporosis is and what calcitonin
is doing because if we can understand
those two processes we can know hey what
should we be looking for as the nurse
okay so let's do a recap about
osteoporosis what we learned in our
latest nclex review that osteoporosis is
thinning of those bones specifically
that spongy bone that's in the bones
it's already naturally porous but what
happens is it becomes increasingly
porous which lowers our bone density so
they're at risk for fractures real easy
fractures so inside that spongy bone we
talked about osteoclast and osteoblasts
and osteoclasts consume the material in
that matrix specifically calcium and
puts it back into our blood system and
the osteoblast will take the calcium
from our blood system and build up that
bone matrix and keep it nice and strong
however with osteoporosis like the
patient was post menopausal they have
low estrogen levels it can lead to
osteoporosis and things like that this
patient has been prescribed calcitonin
now calcitonin is naturally produced by
our thyroid gland and it helps maintain
our
calcium levels in a sense it's one of
those hormones that play a role in bone
health
so
whenever our calcium levels are high our
thyroid gland
secretes
calcitonin so what's calcitonin going to
do well calcitonin will decrease
osteoclast activity
so it's going to decrease
how these cells are consuming bone
because remember those cells consume
bones and it releases the calcium into
the blood we're going to slow that down
because we don't want
to be
wasting any more of our bone matrix we
need it and this is going to allow those
osteoblasts in a sense to outwork those
osteoclasts because we're going to be
building up bone better than we're
actually breaking it down but this is
going to really mess with our calcium
levels because we're not going to have
those osteoclasts to go in there and
break that bone down to give us some
more calcium
now
also calcitonin messes with how the
kidneys excrete calcium it's going to
decrease it i mean it's going to
increase the secret excretion of calcium
so you're going to be releasing all this
calcium into your urine so you're going
to be wasting it so blood levels are
going to drop even more and then your
osteoclasts aren't going to be as active
and breaking down that bone and getting
that calcium from the bones so what's
going to happen to our calcium levels
possibly and we have to monitor the
patient for this we have to monitor them
for hypocalcemia
so whenever you are looking at your
options you need to be thinking about
that electrolyte in balance so in order
to best answer this question we need to
know how calcitonin really worked and
one of its side effects if we have too
much going on in the system we can have
hypocalcemia so let's look at our
options and see which one goes along
with hypocalcemia okay a constipation
constipation is actually seen in
hypercalcemia
because what happens is that it slows
down that gi tract that stool just sets
in there still becomes hard it's hard to
pass and the patient becomes constipated
so that's
other side so hyper calcium is where you
would see that
okay b
abdominal pain one third distant
distance between the belly button and
anterior iliac spine
well they like to throw stuff out there
at you like this because it looks
abnormal it's like man that's not good
but is it really going to be seen in a
condition of a patient taking calcitonin
no this is what's called
mcburney's point this area right here
and this is what is seen in appendicitis
we learned about that in our
appendicitis video so
this was an appendix question that would
be a red flag but not here okay c
carbo petal spasms while assessing
patients blood pressure hmm what is this
this is true so sign and remember when
we learned when we were talking about
hypocalcemia we talked about true so
sign being positive
and what is this this is where
if you put
some type of device like a blood
pressure cuff or maybe even a tourniquet
on that patient's upper arm
and it excludes the blood flow through
that brachial artery and the calcium
levels are low enough it will cause
these carpo pedal spasms and what
happens is that involuntarily that wrist
is going to flex and the thumb is going
to abduct and the fingers the phalanges
are going to like extend and they're
going to they may even complain of
tingling while this is happening in pain
and it's just going to go up like that
while you're possibly taking the blood
pressure and that would be a huge red
flag you start them on calcitonin you're
taking their blood pressure and all of a
sudden you see that happening so that is
true so sign also they may have a
positive chavat stick sign which is
that hyper excitability of the
muscular neuromuscular system where you
tap on the macedo muscle
in the face and they'll have twitching
of the nose or the lips on that same
side their reflexes are actually going
to be hyper active so looking at things
like that so that's why it would rule
out d so our answer would be
c
okay so that wraps up this nclex
practice review question and be sure to
check out the other nclex questions in
this series thank you so much for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel for more videos